so I'm gonna do pre thank-yous and
that'll tell you guys who I am I want to
thank Jared first for letting me come up
here and speak in front of people that's
always a risk and just as a side note
and I'm not picking on anybody but my
song was the most awesome putting it out
there and I want to thank Mark for
making me aware of DCR making me aware
of this awesome community which from now
on I will definitely be a part of and it
also brings me joy to realize that
everyone in this room likes our that's
excellent
okay so I mean and unusual it's a little
bit about me things I love my husband
you know not beautifully my coffee very
important and my mountains that's uh so
that's me in Ireland that's me in
Switzerland that's me and when we went
slot canyon and that is an incident that
we will not discuss and there's no okay
it's a long story long story so what do
I do when I'm not doing this I am the
director of the analytics program at
Georgetown University go Georgetown go
Hoyas and if anyone has any questions
about that of course please come talk to
me at any point I'm also a professor at
the University so I teach data analytics
data visualization I teach are in Python
which is finally on my background it's
up there okay good stuff so when I got
started thinking about doing this talk
yeah I cheated and I said to Jared you
know what do you think because there's
so many people in so many different
talks and I do something that's
repetitive and he said well how about
Association rule mining and I was like
huh I never would have thought of doing
a talk on that so yeah sure and what was
fun about that is I had only actually
done a lot of that in Python because I
code a lot in Python and I came to our
little later in the game so my
background is computer engineering and I
was around when people were still coding
in Fortran that was actually my first
language thank you very much and so when
I first started with re hated it true
story it was like this is
Kilis and now i love it and i feel like
that that's just a path you have to
travel through with our and so when i
teach you now i tell my students i have
a slide called misery and suffering
because that's really important and if
you don't realize that you will suffer
and you will be miserable and you will
spend ten hours finding something that
you then realize is really easy and
someone else who knows you who you
didn't ask was like oh i could have told
you that and then you hate them forever
okay so anyway let's let's do that and
the direction we're going to go and
today is normally and if so how many
people use do or remember vaguely
Association rule mining just like an see
what I'm dealing with
okay good almost none of you awesome
that's great you won't even know if I'm
saying something stupid so Association
rule mining is an unsupervised learning
method it allows us to do discovery and
from my point of view I love discovery
because it lacks prejudice which as you
can imagine being the director and when
I tell people they're like really so
it's nice for a moment to not have that
reaction with something and we're also
going to go in the direction of thinking
outside the basket if you will so
Association rule mining has a lot to do
with transaction data in fact it has
everything to do with transaction data
so as a beginning we're going to go
ahead and just do a very quick review
the classic review to bring everybody on
board with me so this is from Kumar's
book introduction data mining a
transaction is kind of what it sounds
like it's a collection of items and when
you have a data set of transactions each
row if you have it in basket format
represents a set of items and so
Association rule mining is actually
based on set theory which is nice if you
come from a stats background and not as
nice if if you don't and so what you can
do with this data set is you can create
what I call rules and so I have just a
few of the most common rules here like
if somebody goes in this is not a gender
bias comment by the way but it's going
to be okay
if
male not a male someone goes into a
store and they put diapers in their cart
as it turns out there's a very high
probability that they're also going to
put beer in their shopping cart I didn't
make that up that's that's a classic
example and a gender bias example as it
turns out and so this is what we start
with when we talk about Association rule
money but the real question is what
things are associated and why do we care
and from the beginning of that story you
think well okay if you're a supermarket
and someone's always gonna buy diapers
and beer what are you gonna do what
would you guys do so the women said put
them far away and yes that's what you're
going to do but if you're the a male and
a manager of the store you don't put
them close together so yeah how are you
gonna go with that you know either way
either way you have a plan based on
information based on data that's what we
do that's what we care about so we can
take this a step further and we can then
have measures that answer questions for
us like oh no okay good I have a force
field in technology it doesn't matter so
there are three common measures that we
use for Association rule mining support
which is just based on the probability
of both of the sets occurring together
and just to back up again what are sets
what do I mean so any rule that you can
generate is made up of a set of items
call it the set X it can be empty and it
goes to the set of items Y which can
also be empty so the question is if you
have X what's the probability you're
going to have Y that's that's the big
Association rule mining question so the
support is the probability that they're
gonna occur together that's a good
measure and it's helpful but it's not
enough because what if one of those
items is something that everybody buys
all the time if you're dealing with with
items then it's going to be with
everything and so it's measure is gonna
be maybe a little off and then what if
you have items that come together all
the time but are just not super popular
in general so one of the items is
support the next measure is called
confidence this is basically just
conditional probability there
saying what's the probability that these
items occur together given that the
person has the set of items X in their
cart so that's an interesting and
different measure to look at and then
the last measure we'll look at is called
lift and if you look closely at this and
you remember your stats if the numerator
and the denominator are the same what is
that what's that and what's that mean
independence thank you it's my students
he's awesome ok thank you for knowing
that so if it didn't well otherwise you
know they might fire me if the numerator
and denominator are the same that's
independence meaning that these items in
a and B they don't really go together so
if the lift is between zero which would
be disjointness and one which would be
independence we don't care about that
rule and that's actually important
because you'll get a lot of rules that
actually sometimes they'll have a high
support and other things and you'll
think hey this is cool and you realize
the lift is 1 or something and then you
don't care about it as much so these 3
measures are what are called if you read
this on cran or whatnot they call it
interestingness rules that are
interesting and rules that are not
interesting and these are three
different measures that help you
determine which of these rules are maybe
more or less interesting to you okay so
I'm not gonna read you guys math just
because that would be mean especially at
the end of the day here but if you
wanted to go through and do the
calculations let's just for a second
look at beer and diapers beer and
diapers are in transaction 3 & 4 they
occur together twice out of a
transaction set of five transactions so
they have a forty percent support they
have a two-thirds confidence and their
lift is greater than one so this is an
interesting rule that's what would be
considered interesting okay so in our
there's an also implies on there are
packages that allow you to perform
what's called the a priori algorithm who
remembers a priori who's ever hurried a
priori okay that's good that's great
thank you my students are back there
okay so what this basically does you can
imagine that if you have an enormous
of items and you want to look at every
possible combination of every item how
humongous that tree is gonna be this is
a graph of just five items and look at
the number of combinations there so what
they a priori does is it prunes based on
super sets so it looks at what is what
is some kind of threshold or measure of
an item set let's say the set a and the
set B and remember it can be multiple
items and B can be multiple depending on
how you set it up we're looking at this
as individual items though serve item a
and item B if that turns out that
they're infrequent that they just don't
occur much at all we're gonna prune
everything that's a superset of that
because by definition they will also not
occur a lot and that's how the a Priora
algorithm works and that's why it's
faster because otherwise if you had to
go through this graph it would take
forever and ever so now the other side
of the coin is how'd you get this to
work an R right so in theory it sounds
great we like it we want to see what's
what words are interesting we're
interested in correlation I'll always
put this out as a reminder especially
when I'm working with medical doctors no
offense no offense but correlation does
not mean cause that's right okay just
put that out there so this is a measure
of correlation words that occur together
associations and that bus the name
that's where comes from okay so there
are three different formats that you'll
generally see this in the first one all
the way to the side here is called
basket the one in the middle is called
single and the one over to the right is
actually sparse matrix what's
interesting about the ones you the left
is that even though you can store it in
a CSV file and that's exactly what I'm
going to do it's not a real it's not
really record data right and that
matters you don't want it to be record
data in this case and the one over to
the right is record data but the big
challenge of using a sparse matrix is
you have to know every single item you
have at all moments so if you add a room
of an item you've got to go back and
update that whereas you don't have to do
that they use basket format a single
format so with R and I had to update the
data set because honestly kumar's
datasets disgusting the the food items
and the choices so I went ahead and made
my own healthy sensible dataset yes
these are the items that you should be
eating yeah now you'll notice that the
person the people shopping so I did two
things here one
I removed the ID number because you
don't actually need one and I wanted to
make that something that is notable also
I put quinoa in every single person's
cart quinoa
giveaway that day free quinoa so
everybody had quinoa in their cart okay
which is good you have to soak in and
wash it just FYI okay now what's the
issue here like what's gonna happen is
the support the confidence everything is
gonna be related to quinoa right so I
did this purposely as a teaching example
so people could feel what the measures
mean in instances where things come out
oddly look at also the association
between a coffee and chocolate
that's purposely done as well they occur
together a lot and so when you run this
when you run this in our here's what it
looks like
so the librarian are is called a rules
you will have difficulty with a rules
and if you don't you email me and tell
me how so you'll install it I have some
other if you have it just come ask me
anyway what's going on here is I'm
pulling in the transactions and I'm
going to use the basket format I can
inspect my transactions I can build a
rules object using the a priori
algorithm and I can sort those rules and
then I can look at them so that's what's
going on here with the R code okay and
this is what we get and this is fun
because he basically gives you a set of
rules and it gives you all the measures
the support the confidence the lift and
the actual physical count of how many
times those items or objects ended up in
the same transaction okay and you can
control this too so you can sort by
confidence you can sort by support you
can sort by lip you can control the min
length the max length you can even have
items that have zero in a set and so on
to just see how many times things
actually occur
so that's the story behind Association
rule mining here's the code for you
wanted to use single versus basket just
so that you don't have to go searching
around for how that works so now we get
to go to the interesting bit that was
the review of Association rule mining so
what I thought to myself is yeah okay so
everyone does this for transactions
usually for items and how they're
associated wouldn't it be fun and
interesting to do this for Twitter data
and see what I get you know see if there
are specific words and then the next
question is what's the format of the
data going to look like that's arguably
the most important questions we answer
we do data science data cleaning data
formatting data processing right so I
don't want this to be a bag of words if
I grab in a whole bunch of tweets so
normally when we do NLP or we do text
mining even when we compare document so
we do any of that stuff we grab in we
make a bag of words we make a you know
big CSV files we compare things we're
not keeping basically context if you
will what I'm trying to do here is make
sure that I retain each tweet as its own
transaction that's the goal and so in
order to make that happen and I used I
played with a whole bunch of stuff so I
left the libraries up there and I left
the things that I ran into and how to
fix them up there just in case you are
wondering but the ones highlighted are
the ones I'm using for this talk this
FYI so number one and I'm gonna go
through this quickly because I think
most of you know this part is in order
to do anything with Twitter you have to
get a developer's account you have to
make sure that you get all their keys
and passwords and then you have to put
them into are so there's the code for
that at the very top if you're wondering
what the heck is that because I blocked
some of it out because those are my
actual tokens there are many ways to do
this what I did here is I created just a
text file with the variable names and
then under them the actual values of my
tokens so that I can easily read that
data in and I can easily update it and
use it in multiple files so instead of
hard code
he lives in a file and that's what you
see going on here at the very bottom
what you see is me pulling this into
Twitter so basically saying to Twitter
I'm I'm Who I am and then I use Twitter
and I used a method called search
Twitter now when I was at home doing
this I actually did it on political data
because that's right what you're
thinking already though and it was
really really fun but it took me forever
to try to pull all the profanity out of
it so and I was like I don't know when
I'm gonna do that so I did something
completely safe though it also turned
out interesting which was I love
chocolate hopefully no one's offended by
it by that so when we go through them
that's okay it's part of my [ __ ] ISM
when you take a look and see what your
object looks like if you're familiar
with Twitter at all it's gonna look very
familiar to you and I've read this into
a data frame because I only want to
access the text of these tweets but you
don't have to do that you can look at
the Geo code you can look at latitude
longitude I just read a paper the other
day where people used a method very
similar to this to measure happiness
around the United States based on what
people were tweeting and where they were
located apparently one of the happiest
places is Boulder Colorado and there are
miserable places to it I'm not going to
list those so the key here is that each
tweet has to be a transaction and you
can't lose that and that you want to be
able to access that so this actually
took a little bit of doing I thought
it'd be simple it was not simple feel
free to steal my code because this
actually took the longest of everything
I'm telling you here this one slide I so
what I did to make this happen is I
created a file first and I put the very
first tweet as a transaction in that
file separated as CSV I had to use
squish I had to use unlist
I use a number of these fun methods so
later if you want to play with this I
recommend it because it's not simple
it's an interesting problem okay once
you do that this is kind of what you've
got every row is a tweet so I didn't
lose that context I still have that in
there and so my question is first how
can I clean it and then second What's it
telling me so to clean it
went through a bunch of just you know
your basic steps this is where I look at
I summarize it I take a sample and take
a look at that I looked at it you know
visually I noticed I'm gonna have to
take out all the HTTP all the HTTP is
something called Artie I gotta take
these things away so that they don't
destroy my association right so I
actually did quite a bit of cleaning on
this data let me fast forward to that
slide I'm running out of time a little
bit and so essentially with my cleaning
I used a combination of just getting rid
of stuff by hand it's not cheating you
know you got it you got to do this
sometimes it has to happen and then I
took away things like digits I use grep
l for that and what I ended up doing
with creating a logical list and then
applying that logical list to the data
and deleting things that fell under the
logical true or false so I could explain
that a lot better but not in one minute
41 seconds so this is an extension of
that idea where I just took things away
that were garbage for a lack of a better
word okay then I ended up with a cleaner
data set and then I was finally in a
position to take a look at the rules so
I inspected them I sorted them and this
is what I got and this was very
interesting to me and you get what you
expect a little bit so you get things
like yummy you get things like gift box
and it depends on when you do it like
what day it is and whether it's
Halloween you get different stuff at
different times and so it's it's
interesting as just a general result I
also discovered that there's some really
strange stuff going on with chocolate
there's a community that associate
chocolate with their food porn you can
see it better here in this a rules vic
and so this is actually interactive and
there's an even more fun one but a rules
VIS creates just your basic plots and it
gives you some nice visualization when
you pull it up on your computer you can
move things around and the size is based
on support the colors based on
confidence we're darker the higher
confidence and because it's a network it
immediately gives you the first X I I
chose 10 associations here and you can
do it based on
confidence support or lift as well which
gives you a nice idea of what you have
and so and then we discovered that
chocolate is happy it is a dessert it is
happens on the weekends it is associated
with food pornography and sometimes it
comes in gift boxes and these are the
things people talk about that's right
that's zero BAM that's just timing
[Applause]